the efforts our friend Rich Eisen just
called in wanted to weigh in on Sam
Donald and your take on his not
following at the combo okay Rich Eisen
NFL Network host and host of the Rich
Eisen show hi rich IDP is always
listening to you driving into work and I
don't mean to you know split screen us
and not take us and and this is fully
you know you you could accuse me being
biased because obviously at the NFL
Network we want everybody to throw yeah
it makes for a better show and it makes
for a better makes for a better watch
that said with that caveat said I've
never heard of anybody ever downgraded
because they didn't throw well at the
convoy
Cam Newton threw poorly at the combine
and he was first overall but what he did
prove was that he's willing to go out
there and he's willing to throw to
anybody anytime anywhere in front of
anybody and this reeks of whoever is
representing Sam Donald telling him
don't do it it makes no sense that he's
focusing on an interview or focusing on
running a forty he's going to end up
standing out there in a hooded
sweatshirt while everybody steps up
there and competes and everybody's you
know rooting for each other and that's
what the scouts look for they look for
the competitive spirit and he's just
going to be standing there with his
hands in his pockets and it makes no
sense to me okay but if it if everybody
is sort of graded on this same curve
that that it's not a detriment to
anybody then it's not going to help him
if everybody like everybody's going to
be the same hey you went out there and
you threw I disagree it would definitely
help them you know as you know you know
scouts will nitpick anything you know
one of one of I think I could speak for
your fan base that when you have
accomplished NFL players come on your
show and read their
reports its laugh-out-loud hilarious but
that said if somebody's on the fence
like say Cleveland and it is something
that they will remember in the fourth
quarter adversity is going to hit third
quarter adversity is going in it so when
you step up to a combine in the Division
three receiver you've never thrown two
is next up on the line and you throw it
in the spot the window you're supposed
to throw it and the kids not there on
time
the Scout notices that somebody never
throwing makes no sense to me it never
does
but I guess he's this is the advice he's
been gone and and that you know I will
agree to disagree with anybody but a lot
of these things are all silly in the
first place Teddy Bridgewater apparently
couldn't throw a football when he had
his pro day even though you saw what he
did it
Louisville and then even what he did
when he first got to the NFL you know we
we can make whatever we want out of
these pro days and combines I think darn
'old is you know whatever his approach
is he must feel pretty confident that
he's doing this or he doesn't need to
show his his arm I don't know if anybody
has any questions about Sam Donald's arm
do we have questions about some of these
other quarterbacks Lamar Jackson
Josh Allen yes we do have questions
about them so I can understand where
they have to prove any something I don't
think Sam Darnell has to prove anything
by but he what he does at the combine
thrown the ball well like I said I will
agree to disagree and you can you can
you can accuse me of again being
disappointed because we want at the NFL
Network somebody of his stature
maybe being first overall to throw and
and just get out there and wing it and I
think I speak for everybody in the
scouting and NFL community when they say
look you know we don't have to be there
either technically I mean they could
just do tape and have you in personally
also but everybody's there because it is
something that the NFL has decided and
the scouting community and everybody in
the front office
decided is the most important thing I
mean technically the combine began
because everybody needed to get together
and get medical tests on players and
make it standardized and let all all at
the time probably 30 teams figure it out
you know
so it's morphed into something
completely different now and at the same
time Scouts are all there they want to
see you compete and he's just going to
be standing there and a hooded
sweatshirt and and and I think at the
time it it's gonna be an awkward thirty
minutes of his life that maybe he can
get through and it'll be first overall
anyway and and that'll be the end of it
but it's entirely possible that when it
comes push comes to shove he won't be
first overall because it you know the
team had like Cleveland like sit there
and think well Josh Allen competed Rosen
competed or that's what you know maybe
we can get Donald's fourth let's go get
Berkeley I mean these are it's entirely
possible that does happen thank you rich
more from rich coming up on the Rich
Eisen show at noon Eastern that'll be on
DirecTV audience Channel 239 for more
Dan Patrick show to the audience Channel
239 on DirecTV or download the Dan
Patrick show app
[Music]